sur ce texte extrêmement important qui
est issu de la convention citoyenne moi
je suis rapporteur du titre 6 donc c'est
le titre qui s'occupe de la justice et
de l'environnement et c'est sur un titre
sur lequel on va essayer d'avancer
d'avoir des avancées effective efficace
pour une meilleure protection de
l'environnement et une meilleure
sécurisation juridique de tous les
sujets autour du droit de
l'environnement et on peut éviter les
accidents évitant les accidents c'est
toujours mieux que de devoir les réparer
et en termes d'environnement
c'est un sujet qui pour moi est
extrêmement important comment on fait
pour éviter les catastrophes
comment on fait pour éviter les
pollutions c'est l'essentiel l'écocide
tel qu'il a été défini par la convention
citoyenne et est une idée extrêmement
intéressante
intellectuellement intéressante mais qui
n'a pas déficient sur la réalité des
enjeux autour de dépollution que l'on
constate dans notre pays donc il faut
travailler sur un droit de
l'environnement qui soit efficace qui
punit les gens qui trichent et qui en
même temps protège évidemment
l'environnement et aujourd'hui on a un
droit de l'environnement qui est bien
trop compliquée qui est bien trop
imbriquées entre différents codes et
c'est qui qui qui fonctionne que pour
les gens qui le connaissent parfaitement
et je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait un
travail non pas de simplification mais
de réécriture pour qu'il soit bien plus
lisible par tous les acteurs
ce qu'on va essayer de faire et c'est un
sujet techniquement juridiquement très
compliqué c'est de définir la mise en
danger de l'environnement et comment on
peut relancer sur un délit de mise en
danger de l'environnement c'est à dire
que on est même avant la pollution et on
a des possibilités pour un certain
nombre d'acteurs de se dire de
comprendre que c'est qu'ils vont faire
et potentiellement une mise en danger